you guys ever google something and then  you notice on your facebook wall there's  an ad for the thing you googled  well what the hell is that i was on my  facebook all day there was an ad for  sexy cougars  i was like hey google  that was between us  what the hell are you doing buddy i  thought i could tell you anything you're  blabbing neighbors take it easy you know  now i'm all nervous around google now  it's like that guy i can't trust anymore  you know now every time i google  something i'm very ambiguous now i'm  like  uh spicy latinas  or a friend  can't be too careful  uh  can i just say this to the ladies on  facebook or on facebook ma'am can you  gals on facebook just make a photo album  called swimsuits all right  it would save us all a lot of time all  right  all that clicking you with your aunt you  with your cousin you with your parents  come on what is this a treasure hunt  let's go